The chair now goes to the Amici Qurey who are present here this morning and with the permission
of our esteemed former chief justices and justice at the Supreme Court, maybe recognize
them in the order of their seniority in the court.
So with their permission, former chief justice Artemio Panganiban, maybe recognize you first.
You may speak from where you're seated or you can use any of the two rose rooms at your left or at your right at your convenience
Your honor
Senate president chair win Kachalian
presiding officer Francis
escudero and
esteemed
senator judges.
May it please the honorable Senate
in performing its constitutional duty and power
to try and decide impeachment cases.
Thank you for inviting this humble retired Chief Justice
as Amicus Curay.
Thank you too for allowing me to speak first,
to attend this afternoon's award ceremony of the Foundation for Liberty and Prosperity,
where 20 exemplary loss callers will be granted 250,000 each, five MBA fellows will be granted
500,000 each, and five dissertation writing contest winners will be conferred more than
1.3 million pesos in prices. In fact, your honors assisting me today are the past recipients
of these FLP awards. Arbim Cortez at my back, Rachel Helya and Jacob Barbosa. Since I will
I will submit a copy of my written brief to you, your honors.
And together with my column on the
in the Philippine Daily Inquirer, August 17,
2026, titled "Two Thirds."
I will confine my remarks today to only four points.
Points.
Point one.
As is generally known, an impeachment trial in the Senate
is sui generis, Latin words that mean of its own kind
or unique.
It has both legal and political connotations.
Parsu wants to its legal character, the honorable senators conduct the trial in accordance with
the law and evidence and the rules of court.
With the Cesar examined by eagle-eyed lawyers ready to overwhelm them.
Our people see senators garbed in their majestic crimson robes.
arguing as if they were in a judicial courtroom. Politically on the other hand,
the composition is not confined to lawyers or jurists. Rather, its membership is
open to elected political leaders who need not obtain formal legal education,
need not pass the excruciating bar examination and need not be scrutinized by the judicial
and bar council. Your owners are not sitting here as justices or lawyers. Truly, the Constitution
does not require you to be lawyers or jurists. Neither are your owners expected to act
like jurists or lawyers.
Notably, senators in the United States of America
trying impeachment cases do not ape judges.
They do not even wear judicial robes.
Instead, they are garbed in their normal attire.
But in this hall, you have deemed it necessary and proper
that you are garbed in judicial robes.
That's why in my case, I want to honor also this honorable court
by being garbed in my judicial robe.
Point two, the Constitution, as has been stated
by the honorable presiding officer, states, and I quote,
"The Senate shall have the sole power to try and decide
all cases of impeachment.
When sitting for that purpose, the senator shall be on oath
or affirmation, which you already have done.
And then, critically, no person shall
be convicted without the concurrence of two-thirds
of all the members of the Senate.
Close quotation.
How do judges and justices interpret
the provisions of the Constitution
and for that matter, of laws.
There are two major ways or methods.
The first method is called verba legis.
Words are plainly read and given their ordinary meanings.
In such cases, there is to quote the Supreme Court
of the Philippines, no need for interpretation,
but only application of the provisions.
Close quotation.
The Senate, as we all know, has 24 members
under the Constitution.
Two-thirds of 24 is mathematically 16.
Therefore, 16 votes are necessary to convict.
If we must use mathematics.
Indeed, mathematics, your honors, is an exact science in the abstract.
To repeat, in the abstract, why?
Because 2 plus 2 is always 4 in the abstract.
3 plus 3 equals 6.
2 times 10 equals always 20.
Therefore, 24 multiplied by 2/3 is always 16 in the abstract.
But not always in reality.
There's a difference between abstraction and reality.
For example, your honors.
Very simple.
One small drop of water, when put together with another
a small drop of water may become one bigger drop of water.
So in reality, it is one big drop of water.
Reality sometimes, your honor, changes the denominator
in mathematics.
In the same way, constitutional interpretation
cannot always stop at abstract mathematics.
We must look at the intent and the purpose
of constitutional provisions, the circumstances
in which they operate and the goals they seek to achieve.
Which brings us to the second method of interpretation,
the Russia-ledges-est anima.
or to quote the Supreme Court,
"The reason of the law is the soul of the law,"
close quotation.
The text must be understood
within its constitutional ambiance.
To shorten my presentation,
as we have time limits,
I will leave it to my more learned retired colleagues
here present,
the jurisprudence on these two ways of interpretation.
However, your honor, I have included in the footnotes
of my presentation the jurisprudence
beginning with the 1924 case of Fuentes
versus Director of Prisons.
And the often quoted 1949 case of Abilino versus Cuenco,
which is only the second, not the first, your honor,
on this issue.
Although in the case of Fuentes, this
was decided prior to the Constitution,
but under the Jones law, which was the enabling
act of the Philippines at the time in 1924.
From the case of a Bellino versus Cuenco,
there are several other cases.
Up to the 2026 case of Henry Leo versus Senate,
with which your honors must be familiar,
since it also involved the present Senate
and the present vice president.
Relevantly, your honors may ask, should the interpretation
of the drafters of the Constitution prevail?
With due respect, not necessarily.
In our constitutional allocation and separation of powers,
the principle of checks and balances,
the makers of the law are not the final authorities
on interpretation.
That delicate task is lodged in an independent branch
of government, the judiciary.
And in the present case, the honorable Senate.
Point three, which of the two modes of interpretation
should the Senate use in discharging its constitutional
duty to try and decide impeachment cases?
I respectfully submit your honors that it is neither.
Repeat, neither of the two.
Why?
Because as I already said, senators are not jurists.
They're not even lawyers.
Some of you may be lawyers, but you're not
called here to decide as lawyers.
You're called upon by the Constitution
to decide as lawmakers.
In fact, your honors, you need not even
use language or methods of magistrates with your respect.
You are elected as representatives at large
of the entire electorate.
You are the co-equals of the justices of the Supreme Court.
So how then should the Constitution be interpreted
by the honorable senators?
In my humble opinion, in accordance with their mandate
as representatives of the people,
especially reflecting the common sense of the people
guided by two fundamental standards,
namely truth and fairness.
Truth and fairness.
The standard of truth is called from facts extracted.
One, from studying and verifying the documents
and papers submitted by the parties.
And two, from hearing witnesses
and observing their demeanor understand in front of you.
The tweets of their eyes, their body language,
the tone of their voices, and the spontaneity of their answers.
By watching and listening to them face to face,
Your Honours would know whether the witnesses are telling the truth, the whole truth, and
nothing but the truth.
Fairness on the other hand demands that we hear before we condemn and that all sides
are given the opportunity to explain their language and actions.
It is what lawyers call due process and what ordinary people believe as fairness.
As the Greek philosopher, Tim Stockless, who was not a lawyer, once said and I quote,
"Strike me as you may, but hear me first."
Truly, I respectfully submit that active participation and independent evaluation of the evidence
are essential to discharge the Senators and the Senators' constitutional responsibility.
Point four, is the judgment of the Senate based on truth and fairness, appealable to
the Supreme Court?
a respectful answer is a big no.
Because there is no constitutional provision
allowing such an appeal.
The Senate's decision is final and unappealable.
The only way, the only way by which the court
can review a Senate decision or order
is when the Senate commits grave abuse of discretion.
Repeat, not just ordinary abuse of discretion, but grave abuse of discretion.
Grave abuse of discretion, your Honours, is not defined by the Constitution.
But jurisprudence characterizes it as, if I may quote, capricious or whimsical or arbitrary
exercise of judgment amounting to lack or excess of jurisdiction.
In simpler terms, the court does not review the Senate's judgment merely because the court
disagrees with the judgment, merely because the court disagrees with the wisdom of the
judgment. No, judicial review arises only when the Senate exercises its power in a capricious,
whimsical, or arbitrary manner, thereby going beyond the limits of its constitutional
authority.
Thus, the Senate must hear the prosecution and the defense witnesses, as it already does,
allow their councils to argue verbally and in writing, and study their presentations
deeply.
Only thereafter should it issue its orders and decisions.
In this connection, is it truthful and fair to allow senators to cast their votes despite
being absent from the proceedings?
Is it fair and truthful should these senators be allowed to vote, though they were there
in hiding, abroad, legally detained, sick, hospitalized, or otherwise absent and have
not been able to access and examine the documents, have not heard the testimonies and have not
observed the demeanor of the witnesses? To put it more picturesly, your honor, is it
truthful and fair to the parties, to our country, and to our people to allow those abroad,
looking at the pyramids along denial,
or shopping in the fashion houses of Paris,
or riding the romantic gondolas of Venice,
or deliberately hiding in the dark corners of the world,
while everyone here, everyone here in this hall,
is sweating it out, listening to sometimes irrelevant
and loquacious lawyers, or to humble an ancient
amicus curate like me.
To include your honors,
may I say that you are tasked with a constitutional duty
that cannot always be reduced to abstract arithmetic.
Neither can such duty be performed in the shadows of absence,
nor from legal impediments.
as the elected representatives of the Filipino people,
your honor's mandate, in my humble opinion,
demands a common sensical, common sensical, I repeat,
common sensical interpretation of the Constitution.
Indeed, meaningful adjudication requires
active participation in the search for truth and fairness.
I respectfully submit that only in this manner can your honors ensure a verdict that is fair
to the parties, fair to your honors peers, and ultimately fair to our sovereign people.
Maraming salamat po muli sa inyong pa anyaya at masusing pa kikining sa inyong abang lingkot. Maraming salamat po.
Maraming salamat din po CJ Panganiban, tohos po subod namin pinaparating sa inyo. Ang pasasalamat hindi lamang ng hukuman ito pero ng sambayanan sa oras at karunungan at karanasangin nilahad din yos amin. So maging ito. Thank you sir.